oui effectivement de ces données âgés de
24 et 28 ans ont donc passé aux aveux
hier ils ont été mis en examen pour
homicide volontaire avant d'être placé
en détention provisoire
ils sont donc accusés du meurtre de
nuttall boutahar jindal
un rappeur du sénonais qui avait disparu
le 6 septembre dernier sur un parking
d'une discothèque près de sens
une information judiciaire pour
séquestration avait alors été ouverte
par le parquet d'auxerre
l' enquête a permis l'arrestation de ces
deux suspects et c'est sur leurs
indications qu'un cadavre calciné a donc
été retrouvé hier à michery dans un
puits à une soixantaine de mètres de
profondeur l'autopsié devra confirmer
l'identité de la victime mais il semble
bien qu'il s'agisse du corps denis
talbot tahar
les deux suspects aurait déclaré avoir
eu une violente altercation avant
d'étrangler la victime autopsie devra le
confirmer
l'incendié et l'a jetée au fond de ce
puits pour quelle raison y at il eu
cette altercation
la justice devra le déterminer